hey guys you know in a world that is
full of grooming and skin care products
people forget that the food you eat
plays a huge role on the way your body
looks on your overall health but that
includes your skin as well so in this
video I'm gonna give you the best 7
foods for your skin Hey just very quick
if it's your first time here on my
channel I'm Daniel and welcome to DLM
model life style please subscribe and
also take that notification belt so you
won't miss any of the next videos now
there's no way any more time let's start
with the first food right
healthy nuts especially walnuts why
because they have more omega-3 and
omega-6 fatty acids than most other nuts
which amp up your collagen which
improves your skin's elasticity walnuts
also contain essential fats zinc vitamin
E vitamin C selenium and protein that
your skin needs to stay off tomatoes I
actually love Tomatoes especially with
whole wheat bread and eggs but wise
tomatoes good for your skin well it's
interesting that the tomatoes actually
helps you to protect your skin against
the damage of the Sun how well tomatoes
contain a lot of antioxidants like
lycopene and all the major carotenoids
which protect your skin from sun damage
and wrinkles they also have a good
amount of vitamin C fatty fish like
salmon and also sardines which is a
cheaper option they're very good because
they contain a lot of omega-3 fatty
acids which helps your skin to be more
moisturized and also protected against
inflammation they also contain protein
zinc and vitamin E which makes fatty
fish a superfood for your skin
broccoli now broccoli is amazing is one
of the best vegetables out there that
you can eat for your overall health but
it is also great for your skin it has a
good source of minerals vitamins and
also cartoon nodes that is great for
your skin's health but it also has so
far fame which is awesome because it can
protect your skin against skin cancer
and sunburn green tea now you probably
already know by now how healthy green
tea really is for you but it is also
healthy for your skin green tea is very
high in antioxidant like EGCG which
induces redness the antioxidants can
also protect your skin against sun
damage improve hydration and also a less
that's elasticity
avocados avocados is one of my most
favorite things to be it it's just very
very sad that they're so expensive
in most of the countries in the world
but avocados penetrate cells at the
deepest level and contain high amounts
of healthy fat vitamins A C D and E your
skin needs to stay healthy you know
there's a reason why they use avocados
in skin masks all over the world is
because it really is so good for your
skin
sweet potatoes now sweet potatoes carry
a high amount of beta-carotene which is
a probe vitamin A that works like a
natural sunblock which protects your
skin against sun damage and beta
carotene can also be found in carrots
oranges and spinach now just remember a
healthy skin and good looking skin takes
commitment not a miracle the decision is
yours what kind of food you eat and how
you take care of your skin that is your
decision now if you want more tips on
healthy good-looking skin check out one
of these videos it's gonna help you out
see you in the next video
[Music]